نجوان سمري في تل ابيب تتابع
التطورات السياسيه المشاورات نجوان التي
يجريهاو مع من الان وما هو المنتظر منها
نعم محمد اذا هي مشاورات اخرى من المتوقع
انها قد بدات برئاسه رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي نتنياهو على مستوى اولا هذه
المشاورات ستجرى عبر الهاتف
وسيجريها مع كبار قاده الاجهزه الامنيه
الاسرائيليه من بينهم رئيس هيئه اركان
الجيش ووزير الدفاع ومستشار الامن القومي
الساحي نجبي هذه المشاورات في انعقاد
مستمر منذ بدا هذه العمليات للجيش
الاسرائيلي في غزه قبل اكثر من ثلاثه ايام
هذا هو اليوم الرابع لهذه المعركه بطبيعه
الحال كانت هناك مشاورات اخرى الليله
الماضيه اجراها بنيامين نتنياهو مع وزير
دفاعه في ختام هذه المشاورات اعلن ديوان
رئيس الوزراء بان نتنياهو اوعز للاجهزه
بمواصله ما وصف تدفيع حركه الجهاد
الاسلامي
الثمن الباظ لقاء العدوانيه ضد مواطني
اسرائيل بحسب البيان وبان هذه المعركه
ستستمر وفقا او لطالما تطلب
تطلبت الحاجه لكن هذا اليوم نقرا في وسائل
اعلام اسرائيليه بان خلال هذه المشاورات
التي عقدت الليله الماضيه اوصى قاده
الاجهزه الامنيه
على وجه الخصوص رئيس الشباب جهاز
المخابرات الداخلي الاسرائيلي رونان بار
وكذلك رئيس هيئه اركان الجيش الاسرائيلي
هرتز اوسوا خلال هذه الجلسه
بالسعي والعمل من اجل انهاء هذه المعركه
والتوصل الى تفاهم لوقف لاطلاق النار على
اعتبار ان هذه
العمليه من وجهه النظر الاسرائيليه النيه
قد حققت اهدافها ولم يعد هناك بطبيعه
الحال ما يمكن قصفه من قبل الجيش
الاسرائيلي طالما ان الجانب الاسرائيلي
يحاول طيله الوقت حصر
الاهداف في حركه الجهاد الاسلامي الى جانب
ذلك
مازال ما زالت ربما هذه الحكومه برئاسه
بنيامين نتنياهو تسعى الى انجازات سياسيه
اكثر ربما ولهذا استمرت في عمليات
الاغتيال اليوم الماضي يوم امس وقبل قليل
اوردت وسائل اعلام ايضا اسرائيليه عن
مسؤولين سياسيين قولهم بان الاتصالات التي
تم الاعلان عن تجميدها يوم امس بخصوص وقف
اطلاق النار قد تجددت بشكل غير مباشر مع
حركه الجهاد الاسلامي لكن لا يمكن القول
انه يمكن التوصل الى حاله هدوء في الوقت
القريب سبب المطالب
مطالب الجهاد الاسلامي التي تصفها اسرائيل
بالمطالب الكبيره اذا هذا ما اوردته قبل
قليل احدى وسائل الاعلام الاسرائيليه نقلا
عن مصادر سياسيه اسرائيليه بخصوص وقف
اطلاق النار لكن مره اخرى محمد كما يعني
نتابع طيله الوقت هناك نوع من
الخطابين في اسرائيل خطاب علني يتحدث طيله
الوقت عن استمرار المعركه عن عدم الاقتراب
من اعلان لوقف لاطلاق النار وهذا ياتي
بطبيعه الحال الرسائل الرسائل التهديد
التي تحاول بثها الحكومه الاسرائيليه
والقياده العسكريه ايضا لفسائر المقاومه
الفلسطينيه وكذلك ضمن الحرب النفسيه
والاعلاميه التي تقودها الى جانب الحرب
والمعركه
العسكريه
بالاضافه الى توصيه الاجزاء الامنيه
الاسرائيليه بالعمل على وقف لاطلاق النار
كانت هناك بطبيعه الحال منذ صباح يوم امس
توصيات سمعت من قبل مسؤولين سياسيين
وامنيين سابقين في الاجهزه الامنيه
الاسرائيليه تحدثوا عن ان هذه المعركه يجب
ان تنتهي باسرع وقت ممكن قبل ان تتدهور
الى معركه شامله ومفتوحه قد تمتد لعده
ايام رئيس المعارضه
لرئيس الحكومه بنيامين نتنياهو وقال بان
هذه العمليه نعم انها صحيحه ومبرره من
وجهه النظر الاسرائيليه بطبيعه الحال ولكن
لا فائده من اطالتها ويجب العمل على وقف
هذه المواجهه باسرع وقت ممكن وان كانت مثل
هذه التصريحات تقع ضمن المناكفات السياسيه
بين الائتلاف والحكومه وتحديدا بين يائير
لبيد الذي خاض هو الاخر معركه ضد حركه
الجهاد الاسلامي
الصيف الماضي وحاول ان يصورها بانها معركه
ناجحه وحققت انجازات كبيره الا انها
بطبيعه الحال هذه وجهه النظر النظر
لغالبيه قاده الاجهزه الامنيه في اسرائيل
بضروره التوقف والعمل على وقف اطلاق النار
في هذه المرحله شكرا جزيلا لك يا نجوان
سمري من تل ابيب